does that equate to better results so
and the only reason she's able to do
that is because of the development of
birth control
well I mean look I don't think it
necessarily uh because because again
again back then like your parents were
involved right and you also had to think
of if future gives me pregnant is he
going to stick around
I do I think future is going to do with
baby mom I don't know I don't know
no I thought he'd pay Adam
I had to prioritize the the beta side of
hypergamy you would prioritize like the
the long-term security over the
short-term fun before where now it's
like yeah you can have the best sex of
your life but is he gonna stay and is
that and if he leaves are you going to
be hurt in the long run